normal bug normal normal normal what the
she behold the peanut book
yes that's its name if the rainforests
were a playground this would be its
biggest nerd geek dork poser and dweeb
combined it seems like everything wants
a piece of the peanut bug fort has
defenses galore first of all it's got
some lovely camouflage second bat head
the theory goes that it makes the insect
look like a snake or lizard if that
doesn't work as a deterrent ideally the
predator will bite onto the noggin the
dome is actually hollow and losing it
might give the bug a chance to escape
but this insect hopes it never comes to
that if a predator doesn't get the hint
about the head the peanut bug will
unfurl its wings which have two massive
eye spots with any luck that scares the
fiend away if not its last offense is to
shoot a foul-smelling spray I hear it
smells a bit like a skunk part of the
problem is the peanut bug can't defend
itself by biting it feeds solely on
plant SAP which makes it all the more
curious that legend says that if a woman
is bitten by a peanut bug she has to
sleep with her boyfriend within 24 hours
or she dies I'll give you a wild guess
as to which of the two sexes came up
with that one